Alright. I don't know if y'all noticed, um,
my stuff may have disappeared for a little bit,
so. Was not planning on that.
Apparently,
there was some issue with some of the things that I was posting,
IE, supporting women who want to stay home with their babies.
Anyway, I got it back.
And I want to personally thank TikTok for understanding that
I am just here to support women
and I'm not shaming anyone,
and I love all my followers.
And I'm here to discuss my experience as a stay at home mom
and what I went through when I tried to go back to work. And,
yeah, there's so much I wanna say,
but, you know,
caution tape. I'll get back to posting on Monday. Mwah.